thank you it's a great pleasure to be
back here I think I gave a talk to a few
years ago on behavioral change I like to
think of topics that are topical and I
think big data has been something that
has been around for a number of years
but I think what we're seeing is the
emergence of what I'm calling creepy
data and so my talk is going to be
covering some of that and saying that
there are alternative ways by which we
can think about how we collect data how
it's used and in particular personal
data how how the general public can be
made more aware of it and perhaps even
find it useful so what methods might we
use to discover what people really think
about data that's being collected about
them we can ask them or we can ask them
to fill in surveys but I think one
approach that is perhaps we could try
and use is well as called breaching
experiments and these are originally
developed by sociologists no less
Goffman of garfinkel and a breaching
experiment
the idea is to disrupt the accepted code
of conduct and unstated social norms and
so some of the original experiments that
were conducted in the 70s were to sit
right next to someone when there are
plenty of empty tables in a cafe I don't
know if any of you have done that or had
that experience or whether it's in a
train and or that you're going around
the the supermarket with your cart and
someone comes along and takes something
out of your cart and puts it into theirs
these are what are called breaching
experiments they're going against and
what's normally accepted behavior and
the idea is to observe people's
reactions so when this happens do they
become upset do they pretend it hasn't
happened do they move do they get
surprised or do they even get outraged
and so this sort of gets people to on
the spot if you like and and even do
they question the reality of the
situation so these kinds of breaching
experiments were done in the 70
social psychologist Stanley Milgram also
conducted some of these but I think it's
an appropriate method to think about how
we can get people to think about what
data is being collected about them and
whether they feel comfortable or
uncomfortable about this so a few years
ago a couple of my researchers went to a
chi workshop which was looking at the
Internet of Things and how you might
engage communities and they didn't have
enough time to build something so they
thought they would do a breaching
experiment and it was at the time when
quantified self was all the rage you
know how can we measure ourselves and
how can we use that data what would we
use it for and what they were interested
in was could we do a quantified
community not just about yourself but
could we measure everything or measure
something about the community at large
and so they set themselves up as a
fictitious can they set themselves up as
a fictitious company and they wanted to
see what people would do by running this
breeching experiment so basically rather
than quantified self they set themselves
up as quantified toilets and the idea
was that they would install a urine
analysis technology in the public
toilets to improve public health and
they wanted to spark a debate about
surveillance technologies how would
people react knowing that when they went
to the toilets their urine was going to
be analyzed for all sorts of things in
the name of understanding better more
about that community and would they
would they react badly would they accept
it so what did they do they had two days
to do this to run this they came up with
this signage which says simply that this
facility is proud to persist participate
in the healthy building initiative
behavior are at these toilets is being
recorded for analysis and they put these
stickers up in all of the toilets in the
convention center in Toronto and you
could go to that website and find out
about what was happening
and the narrative was that it would be
for the benefits of society if this data
could be collected because they'd have a
better understanding of the health of
that particular community so they set up
this fake website and that website is
still there I was surprised to see but
if you can look at it it shows the time
the identification of the toilets the
sex of the person who went to the toilet
at that time how much they deposited the
odor whether there was any blood alcohol
was whether there are any drugs detected
whether they were pregnant and any
infections so to make it even more
authentic they said they provided a
table at this website and it showed all
of the great things that this new system
could do compared to other urine
analysis so what do you think happened
well within a day everyone had heard
about it people tweeted about it within
minutes and then it got retweeted the
conference started there was outrage
some people really thought it was the
case that this new system was being
introduced hi there James and but what
we've what they found and I think this
is what was interesting about using a
breaching experiment was a wide range of
reactions to this so some as you might
expect showed strong disapproval which
is health advice it does not get any
creepier some showed concern for example
imagine your employer could find out how
hard you'd partied last night others
showed resignation well I'm sure the
government have been collecting this
data for years others were more
voyeuristic and saying I just spent the
last 10 minutes watching the pee pee
locks can't stop watching them and then
there was humor some people tried to
match people entering and exiting the
toilets with the data appearing on the
website so you wouldn't have got this
range of reactions if you just asked
people what did he think if we
introduced this urine analysis system
into all of our public toilets so we get
a better sense of public health
and so we also found that local media or
rather the as well as being tweeted and
retweeted it a number of journalists got
interested in an article appeared in the
Atlantic with my title of my talk this
week the Washington Post were knocking
on my inbox to ask me would I talk about
this talk to them but that's another
story anyway I think what this breaching
experiment has shown is that you can get
quite a different set of reactions
unfortunately we've been unable to
publish this work because we didn't
follow the IRB ethics procedure and so
even though this paper was submitted to
CAI and got top marks by only reviewers
because it suggested that it helps us
think about based on personal data in a
very different way the the ACM reviewers
rather the ACM program committee felt
that they couldn't publish it because we
hadn't followed the procedures but
that's another story
okay um so that's one approach by which
we can start to investigate and analyze
how data is being collected about us
some of you might be aware that there's
a big thing happening called AI and one
aspect of this is emotional ai and we
now know that there are lots of startup
companies who are interested in in
analyzing people's facial expressions
with a view to understanding the
emotional state that underlies these so
now in a number of stores faces of
shoppers are being taken by their
cameras and converted into biometric
templates and this is used primarily or
allegedly for matching the well-known
shoplifters so that's how these cameras
got set up and were accepted but once in
place they can be used for other things
and now a number of companies are
looking at how long you look at
something whether it's an advert or
whether it's a piece of lingerie or
whatever and your responses to products
machine learning is being used as well
to class
five people who are looking in
milliseconds as to their gender their
age and they're assumed emotional state
and retailers saying well there's
nothing wrong with this what's wrong
with us collecting data like this after
all we online shopping has been
collecting data about people's
preferences about their clicks using
cookies and a be testing for a number of
years and no one's really argued against
that although when cookies first came
out there was a lot of arguments about
whether or not we should be doing this
so that's what's happening in stores so
um the question that I'm raising is our
shop is comfortable with this kind of
physical tracking because they don't
know it's happening they're not aware
that this is happening and the same
thing is now happening with emotional
emotional AI during job interviews as a
startup company in London called human
and they came into being in 2016 and
they argue that they can detect
subliminal facial expressions those
little micro twitches are in your face
that you make and from this they can
calculate how honest how nervous and how
passionate an applicant is when they're
answering specific had types of
questions a hiring company for example a
Stanford might specify what they're
looking for I know there's admit going
on this this weekend it might specify
that what we want are students who are
curious and creative nothing wrong with
that um and human can come along and
take video footage of the various
students or whoever's here and do data
capture analysis and compile a report on
each candidate the hiring company can
then match the results with other HR
data that they might have already on
them so in this sense no one needs to be
responsible for the ethics since the
company is just doing this it's been
asked to they're not making a decision
about whether this candidate is
appropriate or not based on that the
person who is the one that perhaps
is not cast and whether they would find
it comfortable is the interviewee they
are not aware that this is happening so
imagine you're sitting there having your
yes well I'm going to come up to that
but yes if they all wear companies that
make you pee in a cover to do a drug
test and you know you're aware of it you
got to go pee in the car and and maybe
you decide I don't want to work for a
company that's gonna make that decision
based on this and is that the right way
to deal with this or I'm not saying it's
the right way I'm just saying that this
is happening and we as HCI researchers
maybe we need to think a bit more about
are there ways in which we can conduct
research to see whether people are
comfortable about this maybe it could be
that people would feel comfortable if
the interview interviewers were also
asked to have their facial expressions
analyzed so it became a instead of it
just a one-way process so my point here
is to say that this type of data is
becoming increasingly possible I'm not
saying it's right or wrong but we have
maybe as a result as researchers have a
responsibility to think about how
acceptable how is this out do people
feel comfortable sure you could say well
I don't want to go to Stanford because
they're using that method but maybe
staff is the best place to come to study
something and so you are being denied
going to somewhere because the
institution is deciding to use this so
yeah I think that's there so this is
what I'm calling the creepy dilemma that
personalized data collection is on the
rise and there will be other ways in
which AI is being used and I'm not
saying if this is good or bad I think
you know it can be used for very good
applications but there'll be ever more
claims being made and promulgated about
how AI is better than human intelligence
so that company's human claim that they
can analyze the micro risk expressions
in ways that we as humans are unable to
notice and for
not to infer the emotions that people
have and so what might happen is that
what I'm calling a data divide will
emerge from those who are doing tracking
the data and those being tracked and it
raises societal concerns about what my
PhD student Lydia Nicholas has said is
neurological privacy this is something
that you know it's inferring what's
happening your emotions your intent from
your facial expressions that you may not
have control or understand yourself
and this brings me on to the the the
second part of my talk which is are
there other approaches that we as HCI or
social scientists can suggest where it
embraces the data that's been collected
and it's open and it's transparent and
that people are willingly agreed to
participate in the collecting of that
data rather than it being unwittingly
being collected about them and that they
feel comfortable doing so and this is
what last five years part of the project
research that we've been doing which has
been funded by Intel which is called the
interdisciplinary collaboration Research
Institute and we've been looking at in
IOT technology sustainable and connected
cities and how we might use sensors in
the environment and with people to
collect data and what we might do with
it this is just one strand of the
researchers many of you know Intel have
funded many centers one of which was in
London between ourselves at UCL and
Imperial so within the context of my
talk our starting point when thinking
about this is sensing data has never
been easier anyone can go out and get a
sensor and measure all sorts of things
about environment or about your body but
can we make this sense data more
accessible to the general public and if
so how do we engage people in making
sense of it so this is our lab here in
the picture of people who were working
on the Intel I CRI
so our approach having thought about
this is to try and think of ways in
which we can open up the data how do we
reveal data to the general public that's
what's being collected about them their
local environment and where they go can
we trigger curiosity rather than
mistrust or fear why is that data being
collected where is it going what's it
going to be useful and can we engage
them in consciously contributing to the
data rather than it being subliminally
collected and part of our approach is to
try and design very visible technology
by this I mean physical technology that
people can notice and see what's being
collected about them so I'm going to go
through three case studies where we have
developed different ways of collecting
data and analyzing it and importantly
engaging the general public in that
collection these are data about Society
data that's collected in your home and
thirdly data that's collected about
tourism so the first one is about the
census every ten years in all countries
in the world data is required it's
mandatory you have to fill in one of
these questionnaires about that says all
sorts of things about your demographics
about your beliefs about how much you're
earning and the reason for this
collecting this data is so that
governments can work out what's the best
way to distribute funds and plan
services for a community be a housing
transportation industry hospitals and so
on and in the u.s. your next one is in
2020 and apparently it's mandated by
article 1 section 2 of the Constitution
and it also determines the number of
seats each state has in US House of
Representatives
however this thing that's been happening
for the last 100 years or so
it hasn't changed in terms of the
instrument that's being used apart from
going online in some countries the same
questions are being asked all about
demographics
and also you fill this in you don't
really know where the data goes or if
you really are inquisitive you can go
online and try and find a PDF from the
last one but it doesn't really
necessarily help you it's designed
primarily for governments so we were
asked by a working team in the UK in
London who are interested in opening up
the census a bit more to think
differently about how we might collect
data about society and where it might go
we weren't asked to replace it but to
think about additional ways of doing
that and in particular we were asked to
use innovative technology and to think
rather than just this online survey
we're also asked to think about how we
might address the public good by this it
means referring to services like houses
parks libraries and the such which
provided by the government for the
community at large so that everyone can
benefit but to do this we were asked to
think about what information would
people be prepared to give towards the
public good
in terms of the innovative technology as
I said we design something that was very
visible rather than it being just
another app or online survey and we
designed these physical installations
we've done a number of these which was
that these would appear in the public
and that people would see them notice
them and approach them and maybe
interact with them so we designed a
number of these which are were designed
at waist level that people could go
along and answer questions on a variety
of topics and that there would be a
certain degree of privacy so that people
couldn't hear over and see what you were
doing and some of the topics were to do
with health city life trust been a lot a
sense of belongingness and these
questions and themes were discussed at
length with the working party who wanted
to change the way in which we ask
questions of society and we asked three
types of questions the first were direct
questions questions about health for
example what blood group are you do you
give blood have you had unprotected
and there were a number of answers which
they could select the second set of
questions were to do with how would you
mind sharing this the answers you give
with different types of people and these
would be would you mind sharing your
answer with close friends and family
with the City Council or the general
public at large so example questions
here it might be does your mood change
throughout the day do you have any
hereditary conditions how many times did
you visit your doctor in the last year
and third type of question was what
would you like to know about other
people and people who live in your
street or the community so some example
questions were who's living alone in
your street your friend's whereabouts
throughout the day and which local
services are most used in your
neighborhood and so the way in which
people could answer these was through
using this new kind of physical
interface and we wanted to give feedback
to people that they had actually
selected an answer so we had used
sliders and buttons and dials and
buttons that could light up to show
which answer you'd selected so after you
selected your answer it stayed put where
it was so the next person who came along
could see what answer you gave we were
interested to see whether people would
find that an invasion of their privacy
ie they might move the slider back or
whether they didn't really mind um they
were given a smart card by which to put
into each of these boxes and the answers
would be recorded on that so that they
could then use those answers to compare
with other people's so the way in which
it worked was that they would walk into
this room take a card
answer questions on these different
themes and then in the middle of the
room was a what we call a visualization
station where they could put their card
in and they could see their answers
relative to what other people had
answered so you could get a way of
comparison comparing rather and the data
was presented in simple a canonical form
so for example here how many people have
unprotected sex you could see at that
particular time what the answers were
and how many people are organ donors
again at the time it was just before
Christmas so we thought we'd add another
question is what do people do with
unwanted gifts and surprisingly nearly
half of them throw them away or sell
them so you can sort of throw in these
types of questions to see unexpected
results so what did the general public
do this was in Somerset House which is
in London and it's open to the public to
come in there are lots of exhibitions
going on we we put a poster up outside
but that was it we didn't try and lure
people to come in and say look come and
use this but people were naturally
curious they saw these boxes they came
in and nearly a thousand people just
started answering questions and spending
between ten and twenty minutes doing
this going back up to the visualisation
station to see how they compared some
people just answered for two boxes and
went away and others did the whole five
they usually answered on their own but
then they would come back together again
with whoever they were and discuss their
answers and also the questions so what
did we learn from this project where we
were trying to think of a different way
of asking society questions firstly that
people are very curious and they very
interested in that kind of data and
secondly we didn't entice them and it
was very public that they decided for
themselves to have a go
they gave honest answers to the
questions and that they appear to be in
the zone when they were answering them
in the sense that when you go to an ATM
people will sort of just be thinking
about the money that they're taking out
or what they're doing there they weren't
worried about leaving the state of their
physical answers for others to see no
one seemed to be that bothered they they
knew that all of their answers were
going to be anonymous
and as I said groups discussed their
answers so it was more of a two-way
process it wasn't just us collecting
data from them they could think well why
are they asking this question isn't this
interesting
and the presentation of real-time
visualizations of what everyone else had
answered proved to be a good trigger for
reflection and discussion often when you
know we're asking governments ask
questions or need to find something out
they don't provide that feedback or give
information back to those who've given
it in this case we found that it was
very valuable way of getting triggering
discussion okay so that was a data from
collecting it from society the second
case study I want to describe is
collecting data at home and learning a
bit more about this so it's now possible
there are various smart devices to
collect data about what's happening in
terms of the environment in terms of
humidity light noise and so on a few
years ago there was a company that set
up the smart citizen to make this an
open-source toolkit that anyone could
get hold of put it into the house and
measure what they wanted not only that
was that that data was then made open
and available for everyone else to have
a look at and it's still there it's
called smart sis and dot me and you
could just set this up in your home and
then have a look at what data was being
collected but also then go around and
look at what everyone else who's got one
of these was also collecting and you can
see that there you have measurements in
no.2 co2 and so on what we found when we
started to introduce these and provide
them to peoples that they were
interested for a week or so about and
the data that was being collected there
go on to the website but they didn't
really understand what was causing these
peaks and troughs this kind of dashboard
is quite difficult to relate back to
what's actually happening in their very
homes so in our project we were trying
to think how can we
make this more meaningful and more
relevant and that people get more
interested or more curious in this type
of data so what we try to do is to make
the data more tangible rather than it
just being a website that you could go
to and have a look at and so we built
these what are called fizzy cubes which
were intended to be placed throughout
the house that would indicate certain
events that were happening based on the
data that was collected so the the
citizen this smart citizen device was
still used to collect the data but then
we developed further some ambient
displays and here's one of them is which
is fizzy light and the way which it
works is that there's a simple matrix of
LEDs that can be programmed to change
patterns or light or pulse or brightness
this one here it was fizzy move and this
cube simply has a disk on the top that
can go clockwise or anti-clockwise and
it can go fast or slow so these were the
basic kit basic boxes if you like that
we wanted to provide householders to
think about what they might do with
those and the way in which we set it up
was that they could decide what sensor
or what was being sensed to map up with
a particular cube so there were four
cubes for this one was head vibration
one had lights patterns one had air
coming out of it and the other one was
with the rotating disc and simply you as
the user can decide what's being
measured you you click on a box whether
it's noise or co2 and you drag across
over to one of those four cubes and then
you set up the parameters so a parameter
might be if the co2 level is equal to
exhaled breath then alert me by turning
on the fizzy move cube we wanted to have
these end user rules in the language
that people could understand rather than
in numbers that they might not so what
happened we did a a user study in the
wild we
asked a number of families if they would
mind having the smart citizen and then
being given the cubes so they were given
the smart system kit for a couple of
weeks and just to measure what was
happening in the house and then they
could go to the website to see we then
gave them a physic it to see what else
they might do so what happened what were
the main findings well in the first two
weeks there was curiosity about the data
being collected people went and had a
look at the website but then as we had
found before most people stopped looking
at it
even and just got on with their lives
then when we came along and gave them
the physique it what we found was that
people very interested in in what these
cubes might do they made lots of rules
they created lots of rules between the
cubes and what was being measured and
they placed them around the house most
people were really interested in noise
and humidity but less interested in
gases and partly you would hope that the
level of carbon monoxide or nitrogen
isn't going to go up and down that will
cause your cubes to start being
triggered so that's what they were
interested in to see whether they could
trigger the cubes or that they would be
triggered if there was a change in those
two so here are some of the types of
rules they created over the period as
you can see there was a lot of diversity
I'm not going to go through these in
terms of what they matched that's being
measured with the type of cube I will
just let this little bit's example the
fizzy light is set off to visualize the
noise in the house it is placed next to
the television for good visibility to
the entire family and is also used as a
candle hole
[Music]
this user has set up to fizzy light to
alert whenever the air pollution is too
high she placed a cube on our nightstand
and after the fizzy light alerted her
she decides to turn the cube off and
continue sleeping to use her replace the
basil plant on top of a fizzy move and
connected it to an air pollution sensor
as long as the quality is good the basil
will continue to be turned and grow
straight up at the end of the day the
user can tell by the direction of the
open leaves if air quality is okay the
fizzy air is visualizing the temperature
in the house after several alerts the
user decides to investigate and takes
her iPad to visit the smart citizen
website and look at a detailed death
[Music]
the fizzy buzzes positions on the
kitchen counter and connected to the
humidity tree cookies for a while the
cute alerts user that the humidity is
too high Gosselaar to turn on the hips
[Music]
okay so you can see how different
households appropriated the cubes in one
setting mum was concerned that her kids
were making too much noise and so she
used it to measure how loud they were
relative to others in the neighborhood
but found that she was perhaps noisier
than her kids so what we found with this
way of thinking differently about how
you present data to householders so that
they can be interested and curious is
that using this tangible type of
representation made it accessible and
that so often that the cubes themselves
when they triggered events was enough
for them to understand what was
happening but sometimes it made people
even more curious and that they were
drilled down and looked at the website
to understand a bit more about the data
and I think just taking this approach
not always thinking can we try and train
up the general public to look at
dashboards and and other types of
visualizations suggest that we might
think of ways in which we can customize
and build physical devices that show or
collect digital data in a variety of
other public settings and we might think
of hospitals we can think of schools
museums and parks where those
communities could build these types of
tangibles they don't have to be cubes
there can be other devices and so that
the data that's collected and shown
reflects their level of interest and
rather than always thinking as a default
we should just provide dashboards of
data and the bottom line here is I think
physicality can make data very visible
very poignant and also it can couple for
the user that where the data is coming
from and the
to that event and what it means to them
so the the third case study I want to
describe is thinking a bit differently
about how we can collect data at scale
and it's a project that we conducted in
collaboration with people on the Madeira
Island in in Portugal those of you
who've ever been there it's a very
beautiful volcanic island and there are
now nearly one and a half million
tourists who go there every year is
quite a small island and there's only
about 250,000 people who lived there and
so the the local government is concerned
about the economic ecological and and
social impact they're having so many
people come to the island now they have
the massive tourist ships that come true
ships that come in three or four times a
day and offload thousands of people into
this small island so they're worried
it's affecting the islands resources and
the wildlife and so they want to have a
better idea of where the tourists go
once they come off the cruise ships and
also into the airports and so with some
researchers they set up an
infrastructure to try and track where
people go this infrastructure is a
simple passive Wi-Fi hotspot sensing
system that can track where people go by
picking up the unique identifier from
their smartphones it's anonymous but
what it does is it allows them to track
where they go and how many you know what
time and it can be then represented as
people flows and so what they're able to
do is collect data that shows different
parts of the island where people went
and how many and whether there was peaks
and troughs
now this is okay it's quite interesting
data but they were thinking this isn't
you know doesn't really help us
understand what people are doing in
these places and that's where we came
along in that we were asked to think
about how we might enrich or annotate
this data and engage the local
people and also the tourists in
contributing more and maybe even
interpreting that data so would they be
interested in helping to understand a
bit more about how mass tourism is
affecting Madeira would they provide
more information to augment the hotspot
people flow data in particular would
they describe what's happening around
them and their surroundings and also
would they be prepared to try and guess
what these visualizations meant what was
behind the data the troughs and the
peaks and if so how would we do that
what could we design and develop based
on our previous projects looking at
physicality that might draw in the the
tourists in a general public to give
their responses and being engaged with
it so we didn't want to design another
app we wanted to think a bit more about
how we could get people to come in and
be interested curious and engage with
the data so this is what we built which
was what nicknamed Romeo and like the
other ones we wanted to design something
that was at a novel that was a human
height that people would come across and
think what's that realized that it was
collecting data and to be able to answer
questions and the design was public
friend and a friendly interface intended
again using sliders and buttons that
were easy to use and that passers-by
were asked questions about themselves
the data that was collected and the
surroundings and they were given the
opportunity to simply say yes or no or
have open-ended questions and we thought
a lot about what types of questions we
might ask people that they would be
interested in but also would help to
understand a bit more about what
tourists did and where they went
so we asked what we called contextual
questions which is describe the people
around you do they how many have
mustaches how many have wearing hats and
so on we also asked what environmental
questions things like what's the current
mood
around here does this place feel busy to
you getting a better a more richer
picture of what's happening rather than
just simply numbers obviously we ask
questions do with demographics what
nationality are you
how often have you been to Madeira why
are you here these questions were
developed in consultation with the the
tourist board and the local authority as
to what might be appropriate then some
questions about data why does the
airport get busier from me why are there
more people in the port why is it
quieter and so on we also asked a number
of factual questions what's the wettest
month of the year just to see whether or
not people aren't seeing sensibly and we
placed Romeo in Funchal which is the
capital of Madeira near to the tourist
centre and again we didn't stand there
and say come on come and answer the
questions we just waited to see whether
people would walk up to it approach it
and think about would I like to answer
these questions and we found again many
people walked up used it whether they
were in pairs whether they're in groups
or by themselves or in families and over
a five-day deployment there over 500
people took decided to use it many
people looked on and waited but because
people who spent often up to five
minutes or more they decided not to
carry on waiting but they went on so
potentially we could have had more
people using it because this was in
Portugal we had gave them the
opportunity to answer in English or
Portuguese and so you can see that a
number of people answered in Portuguese
suggesting that it wasn't just the
tourists on the big ships coming from
Europe and and further afar we also
found that a lot of people just aren't
suggest no but there were some who
answered typed typed in their answers
and sometimes it was found that the
public were more accurate than a sense
of ater so they were asked how many
people each day come into the airport
and most people said 3,000 for that
particular month however the actual hot
spot Wi-Fi analysis was forty one day
and I said yes
it was 7000 so it was possible that they
were able to be more accurate and than
the automated system so this just goes
to show again how long they took to
answer question some people actually
came back with other members of their
group to show them and to answer more
and they were also able to provide some
suggestions as to what was behind the
data these data visualizations have been
collected so when something like this
was presented why is the central part of
French are so busy at 10 o'clock many of
them said bolo do CACO and have you've
been to madeira will know that this is a
traditional Portuguese bread that's sold
at that particular point and everyone
who goes there to buy it just not sold
at other times again they were able to
answer questions like why are there more
people at the airport on Mondays and
some of them suggest it's because of
more incoming tourists or business
flights why does it get busier any in
the area from May onwards again some
suggested it was more events in May and
there are more tourists these are kind
of fairly straightforward questions and
some other ones they found more
difficult but we wanted to see whether
people were prepared to have a look at
visualizations and think what was going
on so opening up the tourist data just
like with the previous case studies with
opening up environmental data what we
found was that having this physical
interactive installation was very good
at attracting the public who would
approach it and then they were willing
to contribute more data and they felt
comfortable doing so and they were
curious about the the people flow
visualizations where people were going
across the island but they were quite
limited in their ability to map these to
actual events so this suggests that you
know our our hope that they could become
data detectives maybe not the case
because it's difficult to imagine
yourself what was happening there say a
week ago or yesterday even the tourist
board and the local authorities were
really excited by this approach and they
came up with new questions to ask that
they hadn't thought
before and so too just to summarize we
think that this approach to engaging the
general public in a voluntary way to
give descriptions of what they're seeing
and to answer questions can generate a
richer picture of what's happening on
the island rather than just getting
automated pupil flows that you can get
from doing this Wi-Fi hotspot analysis
ok I'm just going to come to the end of
my talk now which is some of the the
lessons learned from these three case
studies with that very visible look at
me
types of displays and technologies are
attractive to the general public they'll
come up they're curious they'll approach
them and their access if they're
accessible they feel comfortable
interacting and providing responses the
use of colorful physical and simple
interfaces which I hope you've seen
through through those three makes it
easy for people to feel that it's okay
for them to have a go and not worry that
that they might make a fool of
themselves or they won't know how to
answer the questions showing others what
how others have responded seems to be a
really key way by which people are
intrigued and curious and it gets them
reflecting about their behaviors and
then people are much more interested in
data that they can connect with that's
what we saw with the physic it with
what's happening in their own lives and
then creating a sense of ownership
towards the data can make people curious
so just to recap I think these physical
interfaces there's a lot to be said
about designing something that's
colorful that's attractive in terms of
provoking curiosity and using familiar
inputs like sliders and knobs and dials
there's something about that experience
of doing that rather than just clicking
on radio buttons that makes people want
to do more they can also see how many
questions there are to answer and rather
than there being potentially hundreds on
an online survey so just to summarize I
started my talk by
saying what's happening in some aspects
of society in terms of how we can
collect data and how creepy that might
be and clearly this is on the rise
whether you think it's creepy or not
depends on your perspective of whether
you're the one who's the company that's
trying to introduce a new service but I
argue I think we need more user studies
to explore what people are comfortable
with and especially with AI analysis
that try and analyze and interpret and
infer people's expressions without them
knowing or their consent also I think
researchers should take risks more risks
to reveal because I think just asking
people may not you may not get the whole
picture and conducting breaching
experiments like this I described at the
beginning is one approach and human
beings are very naturally very curious
and that's what I think we've shown in
all of our studies so let's try and tap
into this by enlisting them to collect
and interpret their own data in
conjunction with AI approaches I think
I'm not against AI approaches I think
you know they have a lot to offer but we
need to think about how people humans
can understand these interact with them
and feel that they are comfortable and
they accept how they're being used so on
that note I think I will finish and say
thank you very much at all my colleagues
and collaborators thank you
[Applause]
your questions and comments in your
census I remember you had the option for
people it's like saying what kind of
family or or like with your friends or
life or like the government aside rather
like do people's differ significantly
like who they want to share it with
based on like their own demographics and
stuff like that writers because that
would like indicates a potential problem
with this approach of like of like like
asking users for a lot of I don't think
we found any systematic differences
between how the types of questions that
were asked and whether people felt
comfortable sharing this certainly there
were some differences but nothing
systematic so that I think was one thing
we were really interested in seeing
whether or not people you know would be
feel most uncomfortable if their family
or friends knew that they were having
unprotected sex or something like that
but because it was anonymous B and in
that setting it was hypothetical but if
it was in the real context you might
find that people would be quite
different about who it was going to be
shared with but we were just exploring
whether how much they would you know how
far they were prepared to let that
information be shared so I'm curious
about the issues with it's about ethics
of the research or just criticism of the
research I've observed certain parts at
least of the HCI community will say oh
we think this is an invasion of privacy
or something and and we'll kind of
precise the work and not want you to
even do it and I you know I've been on
panels with people with this attitude
and I'm wondering whether that's
actually a real mistake because only by
building these systems and seeing how
people really react can we understand
what are the right lines to draw versus
just hypothetically going hey
one like that or that is inappropriate
ammonia is some of these kind of probes
almost that you're doing allowing you to
get at that and was that also some of
the issues with that kind paper that was
held up yeah we have an aversion to
harming people and so ethics you know
it's very easy to get on your pedestal
and say what's right and what's wrong
and we should protect for all people and
so on and so forth but these
technologies are coming out which are
much more insidious and I and I I'm in
total agreement with you that I think we
need these kinds that we need to do
these kinds of studies just like ten
years ago when fishing experiments as in
pH is H started to be conducted to show
just how gullible and how trusting
people were when an email was sent to
them from what looked like their bank
saying could you please give me details
and people just filled all that in and
so I think we need now because of all of
these new technologies that are coming
out to do more experiments to look at
the what people's reactions are simply
say that's unethical doesn't mean to say
it's going to go away it's going to be
this not HCI researchers it'll be others
who are developing this so that's what
I'm suggesting we need to think about
you know let's not just sort of say oh
we're not going to do that we need to
make sure our algorithms are transparent
and ethical other people won't think
that and so sometimes people don't mind
sometimes they do and I think that
boundary between what is the privacy
boundary between what's comfortable
people are comfortable with and not will
change or vary depending on generation
on culture and so on so I totally agree
with you but I do think that within the
HCI community it's much easier to to get
on your pedestal and say we want to be
protective of all of this and without
realizing that you're actually denying
doing some really important research
my sections regarding the tourist level
so that was kind of a self-report data
that you're using right so we can also
find similar data on several sites like
Twitter on TripAdvisor
so what I think crowdsourcing and
sentiment analysis it is also very
valuable methodology that we're starting
to use in HCI so that could complement
this by asking people but it requires
them to go online whether they've got a
phone or they're at a PC or a laptop
what the what this approach is is that
people just stumbling across it you get
quite different types of people
diversity so those people who tend to go
online and want to help others out
through crowdsourcing may be more
homogeneous and so I think this allows
for a richer diversity by just happening
to to come across something and whilst
you're there so I think it complements I
wouldn't say one or the other I think
each of these methods can provide more
information and a better picture
certainly with with crowdsourcing you
get many more but do you get that
diversity and I think that's quite
interesting to explore but I think my
point is that we shouldn't just always
be going for more autonomous systems
that doesn't that do everything for us
because it's easy we can just put more
sensors out there we've got this other
one they're not necessarily reliable
accurate but they only give you a
particular line through what's happening
so yes what's the process of like
designing these like probes how do you
select the right Pro because you know
you can induce biases on the person you
know a probe can be an intervention by
itself and may actually generate a
change how do you discuss this like
shall I do like you know I think that's
less square versus less square whatever
it's I'm just curious what
the process of getting to creativity a
bit of serendipity a lot of prototyping
in the lab I hire professional
interaction designers who understand you
and I are inspired about what's the best
way to design something physical like
the physique it and so on so it's
interaction design writ large that often
goes on in terms of whether we you know
we developed our first what was called
voxbox which is this very large
interactive questionnaire that was
physical and that was so successful that
that led us to design a whole range of
other physical questionnaires and that
was partly yeah we just had one of those
aha moments let's try it like that and I
think partly that's what you know when
you're doing design you don't really
know what you know what you're going to
come up with but then we do those sort
of post hoc analysis of why did this
work why didn't this work why did people
come up to it why did you know they
ignore it or so on the Romeo we've been
thinking a lot about anthropomorphism
how much and how little you might
introduce so it had a bowtie it was just
and then in these eyes just a little bit
not trying to make it into a robot but
just a little bit we had hoped it would
be able to move around so it could go up
to people and they might use it but
anyone who does work in robotics knows
that's notoriously difficult before it
falls over so we decided to keep it
stationary so yes there's a lot of work
that goes on behind the scenes about
thinking about you know even just the
sliders the buttons and so on and and
that's the joy and pleasure of people
who do interaction design and graphic
design and physical product design
they're seeing how they buy cannabis
display attractive what attention for
people I'm wondering if we just have the
same amount of busy cubes but replaced
them with like touch screens and make
them the same level of present acts and
accessible in people's homes with the
storage his name
we didn't do a test to see whether if
you just went for default tablets I
think there's something about having
artifacts in your home that you you can
customize or dress up or put there so
when you have visitors come you can
explain what that is if you just have a
tablet you don't have that association
or that attachment in one of our first
studies where we were looking at how we
could get people to use the stairs
rather than the elevator we put twinkly
lights in the carpets so as they walked
along the twinkly lights came along and
it lured them to use the stairs people
carried on using those for a year they
became very attached to these twinkly
lights and whenever they had visited
they would show them they would dance
with them and so on
it became part of the furniture so I
think these cubes you can dress them up
you can put plants on them they create a
very different relationship that the
person can have so I don't think you
would get that necessary with a tablet
also tablets you tend to you know you
take them to do other things on they are
multi-function multitask whereas these
cubes are very much just about this has
been programmed to show you when noise
level is high or when the temperature or
the moisture levels are high so they
serve a specific purpose they're not
like a tablet that could be used for
anything
tablets get lost kids take them into
their bedrooms so I would probably say
that we you know you could probably get
the same functionality but you'd get a
very different experience more about the
impact of legislation and regulation in
your research especially the gdpr in
Europe so if you could talk a little bit
more about the legislation and
regulation in this collection of data
especially the GDP are in Europe general
data protection relation I think that is
changing the legislation about what they
just being able to be collected that's
that's beyond the scope of my knowledge
sorry
here please crowd around then you know
ask her whatever you're interested in we
have like to thank her one more time for
coming
[Applause]
you